My name is Kosei Inoue.
I won the gold medal at the Sydney Olympics...
...and the gold in three world championships.
It's been one and a half year since I came here.
I was sent by the JOC, Japanese Olympic Committee, as a visiting trainee coach.
A judo master called Mr. Gonichi Koizumi came from Japan and spread judo here...
...and he established this training school.
In those days, a number of judo masters traveled around the world...
...to spread judo beyond Japan for the first time...
...and we have to respect this historical effort of our former masters,...
...and pass this legacy onto future generations.
I think that British people are always looking forward...
...and expect a bright future.
At the same time, they respect traditions and preserve them well.
This is very similar to Japan.
I teach the advanced level athletes.
Basically, the training consists of free fight practice and pinning techniques.
English people are the majority, but people from other countries are also here to practice judo.